Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am going to
explain an American science fiction comedy film
called “What Planet Are You From?”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The movie begins on a planet far away from earth
that holds only male population. They are a
thousand times more advanced in technology and are
highly evolved. The people of the planet reproduce
by cloning. Because of this, their reproductive
organs have shrunk and disappeared. The lack of
females has caused men to evolve into emotionless
creatures. With each succeeding generation,
the inhabitants of the planet are growing
more ambitious to rule the entire universe.
Currently, they are planning to take over the
earth. The ruler of the planet, Graydon plans
to breed a human-alien hybrid to use them for
his own good. For this, they train their finest
men to go to the earth, woo a lady, and impregnate
her. In the training, they are taught how to flirt
and have sexual intercourse. The leader stresses
them to compliment a woman’s scent and her shoes
which is sure to land them a date. After
days of training, they choose the best flirt
of their kind, H14496 for the mission to earth.
He is going to be known as Harold Anderson. The
leader asks Harold to be careful because no
matter the training, the people on earth are
unpredictable. Before he sets off for earth,
they attach him with an artificial appendage
that will help him have sexual intercourse.
On earth, an airplane is in the air flying to
Phoenix, Arizona. All of a sudden, the pilots
notice something flying towards them at great
speed. Moments later, the mysterious force crashes
onto the plane and makes it move aggressively. The
said forces were Harold and Graydon who have now
entered the plane through its toilet. They make
fun of earth’s backward technology and revise
everything about the mission one last time.
Graydon wishes Harold luck and flushes himself
off the plane. Following that, Harold gets out
and immediately starts to flirt with the air
hostess. Most of the passengers are shaken
by the turbulence they just faced so the woman
thinks it is weird that the man is hitting on her.
She angrily asks him to take a seat. Harold sits
beside a crying woman who is clearly traumatized
by the incident. He compliments her shoes
and her smell but gets no positive response.
He realizes that the mission is not going to
be easy but he is determined to get someone
impregnated. After the plane has landed, an
employee of the FAA, Roland Jones is called
to inspect the cause of the heavy turbulence. He
has been working in the FAA for years and believes
that all “undefined” activities that happen on
the plane are either caused by a flock of birds
or by a drunk crew. He is then handed a video that
a passenger took when they hit turbulence.
Somewhere else, Harold gets off the plane and
starts to hit on every woman he sees. When a woman
bends over, his crotch starts to make a whirring
noise. He figures that the artificial organ has a
defect that whenever he is turned on, it starts to
make noise. The woman runs away after hearing the
vibration coming from his pants. Following that,
Harold goes to the bank he is supposed to work
at. He has already been hired because of Graydon’s
influence. A co-worker Perry Gordon befriends him
and teaches him the ins and outs of the bank. He
also introduces Harold to the office manager and
his girlfriend Rita. Then, Harold meets his boss
who claims he is also seeing Rita. Somewhere else,
Roland watches the video from the airplane and for
the first time in his life, he cannot explain what
caused the turbulence. The challenge excites him
and he makes it his mission to solve the mystery.
After work, Perry brings Harold to a strip club
to get him a girl. They meet a sex worker Cheryl
who agrees to spend the night with him. Harold is
beyond excited but Cheryl is weirded by the loud
whirring sound from his crotch. Moreover, she
asks him to wear a contraceptive which defeats
his entire purpose. The next morning, he briefs
Perry about the disastrous night. Perry promises
to take him to an AA meeting which he claims
is an even better place to pick up girls.
That night they visit one and listen to stories
about women’s struggle with alcoholism and
sobriety. One woman named Susan Hert catches
Harold’s attention. After her speech, he
approaches her but is stopped by the air hostess
he met on the flight. She asks him to spend the
night with her. Outside, Perry accidentally bumps
his car into Susan’s car and the two get into
an argument. Somewhere else, Harold and the air
hostess are in bed together. Everything goes well
until she gets a call from a married pilot who
she loves. Harold comments that she is helping him
cheat which makes her kick him out. Roland’s wife
thinks that he is cheating on her because he has
never been this excited to go to work. He tries to
explain that he is excited about the incident that
took place at work but she doesn’t believe him. At
work, Perry’s wife Helen comes to meet him. Harold
is instantly attracted to her but is disappointed
when he finds out she is married. Moments later,
he notices Susan talking to the receptionist. She
has come to meet Perry to talk about the damages
he caused the previous day. Harold introduces
himself and asks her out immediately. Susan finds
out that he was in the AA meeting to look for
girls and refuses to go out with him. However,
a persistent Harold convinces her for a date.
They go to a restaurant for dinner at night.
Harold doesn’t tell her much about himself
and listens carefully when she speaks.
Not knowing that he has been trained to do this,
Susan is impressed. He also claims that his motto
in life is to have a child which makes her believe
he is not like a typical man. After dinner,
they go back to her apartment. Harold hopes
to get lucky tonight but his plans go in vain
when Susan reveals that she is saving herself
for marriage. He panics and runs to the washroom
to call Graydon. The leader advises him to
do whatever is necessary to impregnate her,
even if it means to marry her. Somewhere else,
Roland interviews the cabin crew to try to solve
the mystery. The air hostess tells him that all
the passengers were panicking except for Harold
who seemed rather calm. When he checks the
passenger’s list, he discovers no one of that
name was aboard the flight. The air hostess
reveals that she went on a date with Harold
and also tells him about the strange humming noise
that his crotch made when they were together. The
man now has all the reasons to believe that the
unexplained turbulence was because of Harold.
Susan comes to visit Harold while he is at work.
She hopes to go out for lunch to make up for the
disastrous date. Harold brings up the topic of
marriage and asks her if she has thought about
marrying him since last night. Susan thinks
he is joking, so to make her believe him,
he gets on his knees and proposes to her. Even
though she is taken aback, she doesn’t decline his
offer right away, instead, she asks for some time
to think about it. Later that day, she meets her
friends to ask for their advice. All of them warn
her against marriage but Susan has already made
up her mind. She claims that she is running out
of time and cannot miss the golden opportunity.
She calls Harlord and agrees to marry him. A few
days later, Harold does a week’s worth of his
paperwork and hands it to Perry. Following that he
takes a leave for the wedding. On his wedding day,
Susan recites a paragraph-long vow but he
only says that he is very happy to marry her.
They are announced husband and wife and sent
on a honeymoon. Harold has sexual intercourse
for the first time and is overjoyed.
Back in the bank, Perry submits Harlod’s
paperwork as his own. He also talks badly about
him to his boss to get a promotion. When Harold
gets back to work, Roland visits him. He inquires
about the flight ticket of the plane he boarded to
get to Arizona but Harold claims he has thrown it
away. To find out if the air hostess was telling
the truth, Roland deliberately drops a playboy
magazine on the desk. Harold’s crotch makes a
humming noise but he manages to hide it with a
pencil sharpener. When he returns home that day,
he hardly acknowledges his wife and her friends
in the living room and walks to the bedroom.
Susan is upset about his rude behavior but is
sympathetic when he says he had a bad day at
work. He is also worried because Susan hasn’t
gotten pregnant yet. She assumes that because
of her history of alcoholism, she cannot have
a child. It doesn’t mean much to her because
she can still adopt a kid but Harold hopes
that it is not true. He then boards another
flight to talk to Graydon. The man says that
no matter what, he has to impregnate someone.
If Susan cannot get pregnant, he will most
definitely have to cheat on her. Somewhere else,
Roland gets a call reporting him of a similar
jolt that a plane faced. When he finds Harold
on the passenger list, he starts to believe
the man is not human. That evening, he follows
Harold to the bar to keep an eye on him. Harold
meets Perry’s wife Helen who seduces him.
The two return to her house but Harold’s
appendage starts to malfunction midway. He
runs to the bathroom and tries to restart it.
Roland is outside the window watching him. He
takes a picture and runs away. Following that,
Harold feels guilty for cheating on his wife and
returns home. He is met with a pleasant surprise
when Susan tells him she is pregnant. The couple
is overjoyed at the news. Meanwhile, Roland’s
wife finds Harold’s naked pictures in his drawer
and assumes that her husband is gay. No matter
how much he tries to explain that he is tracking
down an alien, she doesn’t buy his story. In the
meantime, Harold and Susan go to the doctor’s
and find out that their baby is growing at an
exponential rate. Although Susan has been pregnant
for only four weeks, the fetus is four months old.
When Harold comes to work the next day, he finds
out that Perry has gotten the promotion because of
the paperwork. Perry mocks him and accuses him of
sleeping with Helen which causes a huge argument
between them. The fight ends when Harold punches
him in the face. At home, he tells Susan about
the incident and cries for the first time.
Meanwhile, Roland tells his superiors about his
theory. They don’t believe him fully but permit
him to investigate the situation further. Only
after three months of pregnancy, Susan goes into
labor. Harold drives her to the hospital
and she gives birth to a healthy baby boy.
The smile on Harold’s face turns into a frown when
he sees Graydon outside the room. A while later,
he tells Susan that he will have to leave now.
Susan doesn’t ask him a lot of questions out of
surprise. She blames herself for believing him
and cries as he leaves. He boards another flight
to return to his planet. Roland also follows him
behind to see what he exactly does to make the
entire airplane move. Harold walks into the
washroom but before Roland can get to him,
the plane experiences turbulence. To Roland’s
surprise, Harold disappears from the airplane.
He reports the incident to his superiors
who don’t believe him and fire him from
the job. Back on Harold’s planet, he tells his
fellows that they should aim for universal peace
instead of universal domination. Because of
this, he is arrested. He also finds out that
his baby has been kidnapped and brought
to the planet. An agitated Harold takes
his baby and runs away to the earth.
He appears before Susan who quickly holds
the infant. She is furious at him for everything
he has done. Harold proves to her that he is an
alien by flashing a bright light out of his
nose. He says that he was made to leave her
but she doesn’t forgive him. When he comes
outside, Roland catches him. However, the man
has already been fired so he doesn’t care about
Harold’s secret. As they talk, Graydon appears
and points a gun at them. But Roland shoots him
dead because he can do any harm. Moments later,
Susan runs outside and says that she loves him.
The two reconcile and share a passionate kiss. In
the following scene, the couple is renewing
their vows in a tower. After the ceremony,
Harold tells her that he has been selected as
the new leader of their planet. He plans to
commute to stay closer to his family.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.